Lo que vamos a hacer aquí será sumar 48,029
a 233,930. Como siempre, los invito a que
pausen el video y traten de hacer esta suma
por su cuenta, y después vean si obtuvieron
el mismo resultado que obtendremos juntos, y
si no es así vean por qué. Supongo que ustedes
ya lo intentaron por su cuenta, así que a
mí se me ocurre resolverlo de la siguiente
manera. Primero vamos a escribir el número más
grande arriba. Voy a usar el método tradicional,
aunque hay muchas formas de sumar números de
varias cifras, pero yo voy a usar el método
típico. Después escribo el número más pequeño,
pero me aseguro de que cada cifra coincida con
el valor posicional que le corresponde: las
unidades de la cantidad más pequeña tienen
que coincidir con las unidades de la cantidad
más grande. El número tiene decenas de millar,
así que en esa posición comenzaremos a escribirlo.
48,029: nos quedan 9 unidades con 0 unidades,
2 decenas con 3 decenas, 0 centenas con 9
centenas, y así sucesivamente. Ahora sí,
ya estamos listos para hacer la suma, comencemos
en la posición de las unidades. Al sumar siempre
es buena idea comenzar en las unidades: 0
unidades más 9 unidades es igual a 9 unidades;
ahora vemos la posición de las decenas: 3 decenas
más 2 decenas es igual a 5 decenas. Vamos bien. En
la posición de las centenas tenemos 9 centenas
más 0 centenas, lo que nos da 9 centenas. Ahora
veremos algo interesante en la posición de los
millares: 3 millares más 8 millares nos da 11
millares. Podemos reescribir 11 millares como
1 millar y 1 decena de millar. A veces pueden
escuchar que se refieren a esto como llevar
un un 1: 8 + 3 es 11 por lo que llevamos un 1;
pero lo que realmente hacemos es reagrupar:
3 millares más 8 millares son 11 millares.
El millar lo ponemos en la posición que le
corresponde y los 10 millares que quedan los
ponemos como 1 decena de millar en la posición
que le corresponde. Ahora, en esta posición,
tenemos 1 decena de millar más 3 decenas de millar
más 4 decenas de millar: 1 + 3 + 4 = 8 decenas de
millar u 80 millares. Finalmente tenemos estas
2 centenas de millar, este es el resultado:
281,959. Espero que ustedes hayan obtenido el
mismo resultado. Nos vemos en el siguiente video.